welcome to the show i'm producer pat
ford filling in for david today as he is
traveling up in canada visiting our
neighbors to the north he has some
family members he's seeing up in
montreal so it's going to be me hosting
today as well as on monday and then we
actually have farron cousins who's going
to step in and guest host a couple of
shows for us next week we do have a
jam-packed show to get to today we're
going to be discussing everything from
the mar-a-lago raid to the new irs
agents to alex jones to marjory taylor
green but let's start things off today
by talking about how it's looking even
more unlikely that joe biden will be
running for a second term in 2024 now
even back when biden was campaigning in
2020 i thought that biden is just going
to be a one-term president if he wins
he's convinced himself that he is the
best shot at defeating donald trump and
getting our country back on a path to
normalcy so he'll win his one term he'll
accomplish whatever he can and then
he'll step aside and let someone else
take over and the real reason is his age
right biden would be 82 by the time that
he sworn in for a second term and 86 by
the time he'd leave office after eight
years i'm not trying to be ageist or
anything like that but there's just a
reality to the fact that the president
of the united states is the most
important job in the world you could
argue it's it's one of the most
stressful jobs out there and you're
always busy you have to make these
public appearances not everyone even
lives into their 80s let alone is
working into their 80s let alone has the
most important job arguably in the
entire world in their 80s so i don't
know if joe biden really wants to do
that and over the past couple of years
whenever a reporter has asked about
biden running again for a second term
the white house's position has always
been that biden intends to run but they
never make the full-on commitment
leaving them plenty of room to backtrack
if they decide that you know he's not
really going to be doing this the one
time that kamala harris overstepped and
said that he is going to be running her
office had to step back the statement
the next day uh well now we're hearing
from democratic representative carolyn
maloney who represents part of new york
city that off the record joe biden is
not running for president again baloney
was speaking to the new york times
editorial board and the exchange went
like this new york times's eleanor
randolph said quote should president
biden run again maloney said off the
record he's not running again new york
times is joyouti thoughtman definitely
mispronouncing that said not off the
record on the record maloney said on the
record no he should not run again so
there was a bit of confusion about this
on the record versus off the record
thing both the reporter and the
interviewee are supposed to confirm and
agree that something is off the record
before it's truly off the record which
you can see didn't happen here in this
exchange but her position sure sounded
like biden won't be running again for a
second term she also doesn't want him to
run again as to why maloney might not
want biden to run again that's probably
because of his sagging approval numbers
they haven't been doing all that well in
in recent months although it has ticked
up a little bit over the past couple of
weeks he's back to around 40
but maybe maloney just sees biden as a
liability for the democrats and she
wants him to step aside and to get a new
face in there maloney later went on cnn
to apologize for the statement and to
say that biden's a great president and
she doesn't think that biden's going to
run again but she sure wants him to mr
president i apologize i want you to run
i happen to think you won't be running
but when you run or if you run i will be
there 100 percent you have deserved it
you are a great president and
thank you for everything you've done for
my state and all the states and all the
cities in america thank you mr president
okay so a little awkward there and it's
a little bit unbelievable too because
while she is holding firm that she
doesn't believe biden will be running
again she also doesn't sound that
sincere that she wants biden to run
again i happen to believe her earlier
comments about it are true rather than
this apology and correction and the real
question in this conversation is do
democrats have a better chance at
holding the white house if it's joe
biden at the top of the ticket in 2024
versus if it's someone else fill in the
blank you know it could be kamala harris
gavin newsom elizabeth warren pete buda
judge whoever i could be swayed either
way on this because helping biden of
course is the power of incumbency
presidents do tend to win re-election
more often than not but then there's
also these liabilities right like
there's biden's advanced age uh that'll
be even more of a liability the next
time around because he'll be four years
older there's also his approval ratings
which at least now aren't so good maybe
they'll improve between now and the next
election there's also the question of if
republicans are able to take back the
house and or senate will biden be able
to get all that much accomplished
probably not so then that's hard to make
the case to the voters that you should
reelect him
so to me it seems a little bit too early
to tell what's going to happen for sure
but i'm sticking with my position that i
don't think that joe biden is going to
be running for president again in 2024
and you better believe that that will
set us up for an interesting election
cycle if he chooses not to run again
because then both the democrats and the
republicans will have to be having these
contested primaries to see who their
respective nominees will be and that
will definitely be entertaining and
juicy to cover
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa i have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs i have not one but
two all form sofas i've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable furniture i own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical sofa company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and armchairs everything
is made in the usa using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy i didn't even
need any tools which is good because i
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund
right now all form is giving my audience
twenty percent off all orders at all
form dot com slash pacman the link is
down below